romper la dependencia de los
hidrocarburos rusos especialmente del
gas fue el objetivo principal de la
cumbre europea y también el motivo de la
presencia de joe biden en bruselas el
presidente estadounidense que está en
europa desde el jueves para asistir a
las cumbres de la otan y del g7 se quedó
para ser parte de la reunión de los 27
junto con la presidenta de la comisión
anunció un nuevo acuerdo transatlántico
eeuu acogió con satisfacción la
declaración de la unión europea a
principios de este mes de que reduciría
rápidamente su dependencia del gas ruso
hoy hemos acordado un plan conjunto para
lograr este objetivo
y el compromiso de eeuu de suministrar a
la unión europea al menos 15 mil
millones de metros cúbicos adicionales
de gas natural liquado este año es un
paso importante en esa dirección 15 mil
millones de metros cúbicos para finales
de 2022 luego 50 mil millones anuales
hasta 2030 además de los 22 aportados
hasta ahora para ello se ha creado un
grupo de trabajo americano europeo pero
esto seguirá estando muy lejos de los
150 mil millones de metros cúbicos que
moscú suministra los europeos cada año
del 40% del gas que consume el bloque
cuando los 27 y los estadounidenses
comenzaron a buscar alternativas antes
del conflicto en ucrania el gas natural
licuado gpl apareció inmediatamente como
la alternativa más fiable al enfriarse
el gas es convertido en líquido y se
vuelve 600 veces menos voluminoso
transportado en camiones cisterna de gas
natural licuado se regasifica una vez
que llega a su destino eeuu tercer país
exportador deje nl por detrás de
australia y qatar ya había redirigido
parte de su producción a europa en enero
pero estos cambios de clientes son un
golpe adicional para el comprador otra
preocupación es el escaso número de
terminales de almacenamiento de gn l en
europa que se concentran principalmente
en las costas del continente
la falta de rutas de transporte de un
país a otro dificulta aún más el
abastecimiento a europa central